more and more in North America young
people are not content just to get
pierced or tattooed they want to make a
personal statement in scholars they're
getting their flesh burned with searing
hot metal they're getting branded until
yesterday
Tyler Ballentine had never set foot in
New York City but Tyler has not really
come to see the sights he's in New York
for just one reason to get a brand at
home in Toronto Canada
Tyler works as a professional body
piercer so far he has pierced himself 16
times including the holes he has
stretched in his earlobes he's part of a
growing subculture in North America that
its devotees call body modification body
modification
reshape their bodies from tattoos to
scarification to implanting objects
under their skin body modifiers admit
much of what sets them apart is
dangerous and excruciating ly painful
but nothing they say feels or smells
like having your skin melted away with
burning hot steel
then for his brand Tyler has turned to
Brian Decker a fellow body modifier yeah
how low do you want to go sorry I'm
about halfway about here
to Tyler his brand represents freedom
specifically his freedom to modify his
body any way he wants unlike branders of
the past Brian will burn Tyler's arm
inch by inch it will take several hours
I was him right now in this circumstance
I definitely be nervous Tyler knows
there's a very real chance he may simply
not be able to take it by law Brian
cannot give him an anesthetic
Brian's only tools are a wedge of
stainless steel a vise grip and a
blowtorch from the first strike the pain
is excruciating heated to at least 1,000
degrees Fahrenheit the steel instantly
vaporizes Tyler skin even after the
metal is removed the tissue continues to
burn Brandon is so torturous Tyler is
running the risk his body could go into
shock at the very least his inflamed
skin will remain susceptible to
infection for days to come
you're getting a third-degree burn if
you don't take care of a third-degree
burn and you know that's definitely
possibility for an infection they
obviously could spread gradually Tyler
grows accustomed to the pain and he is
able to lay still and watch Bryan finish
thanks guys hopefully it's gonna look
decent he and all the process has taken
five hours and despite the torment
Tyler is content with his accomplishment
any question he didn't quit and he's
gotten another unique mark to signal his
identity
they hurt really bad but what just made
it all the more worse was the smell of
it and hearing my skin pop I know
there's gonna be mixed reactions there's
gonna be people calling me nuts
but that's kind of the beauty of
modification is because you get to be
able to see who actually looks into
people really if it doesn't really
matter what you look like it shouldn't
matter at all
for body modifiers brands are not just
an extreme way to signify their status
as social rebels there are also keys to
a separate and very elite club they can
call their own